[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacré comme vous le
savez avec tu étais sportif dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
basket l'équipe féminine du chesnay
versailles continue sa marche en avant
ce qu'ils mangent 3 février les filles
devimco berdych ont réussi à battre
facilement l'union sportive de glace
souris dans leur gymnase le score 75 à
39 plus de détails dans ce magazine
cyclisme une compétition inédite au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines ce samedi de février la
structure a accueilli une compétition
d'une durée de six heures au total 24
équipes de quatre coureurs se sont
affrontés à coups de pédales reportage
arts martiaux jérôme le banner lance un
kick boxeur professionnel français et à
villepreux
le sportif est venu donner pour la
première fois un stage de quelques
points à une quarantaine d'élèves
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
on commence tout de suite par du basket
l'équipe féminine du chesnay versailles
continue sa marche en avant ce dimanche
le fcv 78 a réussi à battre facilement
l'union sportive la glacerie à domicile
le résumé du match des images de nicolas
landry un montage de xavier joly une
véritable démonstration les filles du
chesnay versailles en blanc et bleu se
sont largement imposés à domicile contre
l'union sportive la glacerie de scorer
sans appel 75 à 39,7 13ème victoire de
la saison en nationale 3 a été acquise
dès les premières minutes de la
rencontre avec un 13 1 après quatre
minutes de jeu passé les matches qui
sont difficiles à jouer parce que c'est
une équipe qui est bas tableau
clairement qui joue qui joue son
maintien
donc elles ont elles ont rien à perdre à
lyon avec les crocs donc faut faire
attention vos palais faut pas les
prendre de haut faut tout de suite
rentré dans le match est concentré on a
réussi à le faire donc c'est bien je
pense qu'on était sérieux on était
concentré et à la fin les cartes qu'on a
fait c'est je pense qu'on le mérite
cette victoire permet aux féminines du
chesnay versailles de conserver la
première place du championnat
le scv 78 compte trois points d'avancé
sur le duo gravenchonnais angers après
14 journées
des résultats qui permettent d'envisager
une montée en fin de saison
moi j'aime pas trop parler de ça je
préfère prendre comme toutes les filles
d'ailleurs match après match
une seconde saison c'est longuet encore
les play-offs après voilà on sait que
c'est pas parce qu'on termine 1re de la
poule qu'on monte donc voilà on y va
match après match et on verra s'il ya
monté à prendre part m'ont fait
comprendre à auch un match pour les
féminines du chesnay versailles le
dimanche 10 février sur le terrain de
chartres une équipe classée dernière du
championnat un match à la portée des
joueuses de vinko var dietsch qui
permettra sans doute de préparer la
rencontre décisive contre angers à la
fin du mois toujours en basket dans le
championnat de nationale 3 masculine
trappe s'est incliné de justesse à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de tours
basket métropole le score 59 à 56 au
classement cette défaite n'arrange pas
les trappistes et compte désormais trois
points de retard sur le premier poitiers
mais reste deuxième du classement
si on a pu jouer en intérieur c'était
plus compliqué en extérieur de nombreux
matches ont été annulées suite aux
chutes de neige de la semaine dernière
et aux températures glaciales qui ont
suivi dans le championnat de d1 de
district de football match entre
maurepas et monte son propre
mais ce dimanche a été annulé même
scénario dans le championnat de 2e
division de district ou montigny le
bretonneux n'a pas pu recevoir l'équipe
2 de guyancourt le district des yvelines
annoncera de nouvelles dates pour ces
matches dans les approches un jour si
l'équipe 2 de guyancourt n'a pas pu
jouer ce week-end l'équipe
une était bien sur les terrains ce
dimanche en première division de
district et légumes en courtois se sont
inclinés 2 à 0 à domicile contre
gargenville une défaite qui fait reculer
le club à la deuxième place du
championnat alors pour décortiquer à
cette performance nous recevons sur ce
plateau le président guy gallant ti
ainsi que l'entraîneur du talent morose
et le capitaine loïc filiatre bonsoir ça
alors avoir parlé du classement et des
résultats de guyancourt on va revenir
sur ces intempéries qui ont chamboulé un
un petit peu le calendrier
guy gallant thiès qu'il fallait annuler
ces matchs peut-être pas mais
effectivement ça fausse un peu déroulé
le championnat parce que quelques
équipes jouent d'autres ne joue pas et
aujourd'hui par exemple si on regarde le
classement on est un peu perturbé par ce
que il n'y a rien à en tirer pour
l'instant vous avez par exemple deux
matches de retard sur le premier
par exemple au niveau de l'intégrer
l'intégrité physique des joueurs est ce
que c'était compliqué les faire jouer le
week-end dernier à jude sur le week-end
dernier non quand on a des terrains
synthétiques on peut se permettre de
jouer parce que
la neige ont assez c'est bien là dessus
mais sur le terrain en herbe oui c'était
assez compliqué pour pouvoir effectuer
au moins du boulot du football c'était
une bonne décision
oui c'était une bonne décision je pense
dans l'ensemble et au niveau des joueurs
ce que c'est compliqué de jouer dans des
conditions climatiques comme celles de
la semaine dernière nombre écouter nous
on est des compétiteurs on a envie de
jouer on est là pour jouer au football
donc voilà on avait envie de bien faire
malheureusement on n'a pas su en
profiter
on a joué trois matchs à domicile
sur ses trois derniers matches on a pris
trois points à lens alors on va revenir
du coup sur ce match contre gargenville
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
dix ans que l'on a je quand une équipe
qui était très solide qui nous attendait
et donc avec un très très bon avant
centre qui nous a énormément dans grande
difficulté puis ensuite nous on a eu on
a été un peu timorés au niveau du jeu et
puis on a on est aussi il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup d'entraînement donc
physiquement on a eu un petit peu de mal
à rentrer dans la partie et sur ce match
là on a on a pas on n'a pas su prendre
le match par le bon bout et pas par
concrétiser le poteau case aussi con
qu'on avait vous êtes d'accord avec
votre coach d'affaires tout à fond nous
on joue contre une équipe qui était
organisé et généralement dans ce genre
de match c'est la première équipe qui
marque souvent qui l'emportent et
malheureusement voilà on a concédé un
but
président vous étiez en colère après
cette défaite pas en colère je dis qu'on
a pour les avoir vu jouer cette saison
souvent on a alterné le bon l'excellent
et le moins bon et ben on s'était un peu
2 décevant hier mais je crois qu'on est
quand même sur une bonne dynamique
je voulais juste les effets pervers du
du synthétique c'est que effectivement
on a un synthétique on n'a pas pu
s'entraîner mais on a pu faire le match
dimanche parce que les conditions
s'étaient améliorées mais il n'y a pas
d'entraînement et du coup on enchaîne
des matches sans entraînement alors que
d'autres ont des salles nous
malheureusement ne l'a pas et donc on
enchaîne les matches sans entraînement
donc c'est un peu perturbant et
pénalisant il faut aussi s'adapter
peut-être au synthétique également oui
non s'entraîne sur un synthétique
franchement si c'est pas le problème
mais je crois qu effectivement tu l'a
soulevé jeu c'est le fait de ne pas
pouvoir s'entraîner d'enchaîner les
matches alors que d'autres peuvent
s'entraîner mais ne nous font pas de mal
parce que leur terrain est fermé la
problème d'équité peut-être jeu
peut-être pas d'équité mais pas
forcément d'équité mais c'est vrai que
je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya pas
mal de synthétique je pense que
l'intégrité des joueurs n'est pas en
danger si on joue sur le synthétique
donc je pense que là dessus
le district devrait faire en sorte que
quand les matches peuvent se jouer sur
des terrains synthétiques eux qu'on
puisse déjouer pour parce que le
calendrier était assez compliqué et donc
comme disait le président donc on a les
matchs non tout le monde n'a pas le même
nombre de matchs donc c'est un peu
compliqué un petit peu de devoirs
exactement où on en est et pour l'équité
au niveau du championnat c'est c'est pas
terrible alors on va revenir au niveau
du championnat justement le classement
le fait d'avoir perdu contre un
adversaire qu'il est est à votre portée
est-ce que ça peut vous handicaper pour
la suite du championnat
oui bien sûr on l'a vu sur les années
précédentes généralement
on essaye d'être on est souvent au
rendez vous contre les gardes liquide
bas de tableau ouais c'est sûr mais la
dernière aussi on avait perdu des points
justement contre ces équipes de bas de
tableau mais on voit que cette année le
championnat est très serré je pense que
chaque équipe a son mot à dire pour
chaque match et donc du coup tout peut
se passer dans le championnat alors
encore une fois la défense a craqué vous
avez encore encaissé 18 buts en 13
matches c'est trop jude
oui c'est beaucoup trop c'est beaucoup
trop quand on veut espérer jouer le haut
de tableau et c'est vrai que là l'équipe
a un petit peu changé donc il faut
retrouver ses marques et la défense
aussi il ya un peu un peu changé mais
c'est pas trop inquiet parce que je
pense que sur la deuxième partie de
saison on a l'habitude de faire des
parcours intéressants donc je pense
qu'on va se rattraper dès la semaine
prochaine
vous travaillez la défense
l'entraînement on essaye quand on peut
s'entraîner oui on fait beaucoup de
vieux os en place la défense les
offensifs qui font que tu vas y avoir le
sur le terrain le week-end donc on va
travailler on voit continuer à
travailler là dessus pour améliorer
notre note défense qui lie à l'anti vous
êtes à égalité de points avec le premier
du classement ou y las cousy croyait
cette montée sincèrement depuis
plusieurs années on termine 2e 3e
je croise les doigts bon je dirais rien
je me prononce pas j'étais très confiant
des années précédentes et on a toujours
fini sur le podium et pas premier et
avec le premier qui montrent le oui vous
avez peut-être l'expérience maintenant
que vous n'aviez pas sur les précédentes
oui je pense qu'on a le potentiel de
toute façon pour pour monter après va
falloir qu'on arrive à enchaîner les
victoires c'est ce qui nous manque un
petit peu en ce moment c'est vraiment
d'enchaîner pour engranger le maximum de
points
ça va se passer dans la tête ou dans
l'eau dans les pieds au niveau qui était
dans les jambes aussi je pense parce que
l'hiver c'est une période assez
importante au niveau des organismes donc
c'est important de bien travailler et
puis pour être prêt physiquement et puis
a forcément quand on est prêt
physiquement dans la tête c'est beaucoup
plus facile de pouvoir enchaîner les
rencontres au minimum le podium au
minimum et puis après sept années de son
poney vraiment vraiment très ouverts par
rapport à d'habitude donc ça quand son
mot à dire je pense même que on va faire
le maximum pour être là où merci vous
pouvez être passé sur ce plateau bon
courage pour la suite de la saison
on suivra vos résultats avec attention
et comme on peut le voir vous êtes
deuxièmes du classement à égalité de
points avec le premier pour l'instant et
quelques matches en retard
merci beaucoup en tout cas toujours en
football mais cette fois ci dans le
championnat de r3 c'était le choc de
cette division entre le deuxième et le
troisième est le spectacle n'a pas été à
la hauteur de la fiche trappe et
boulogne billancourt se sont neutralisés
ce dimanche le score à 0 à 0 classement
trap est donc troisième avec aucune
défaite concédée depuis le début de la
saison il reste à un point de la
première place si trappes n'a pas marqué
ce week-end en rugby verset ya là aussi
un vrai festival offensif dans le
championnat honneur les versailles se
sont imposés vous le voyez à l'écran ce
n'est pas une erreur 88 à 0 à domicile
face à l'entente gonesse goussainville
la douzième victoire en douze journées
pour les joueurs de la cité royale qui
sont toujours en tête du championnat et
qui ne sont plus qu'à quelques points de
la montée en fédérale 3 du cyclisme à
présent le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines a organisé pour la
première fois une compétition de six
heures sur sa piste ce samedi une course
où il fallait jouer à stratégique pour
remporter la victoire des images de
marylène iapichino avantage de xavier
jaglin une course inédite au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
structure a accueilli ce samedi 2
février une compétition d'une durée de
six heures au total 24 équipes de quatre
coureurs se sont affrontés à coup de
pour soulever la coupe il fallait
parcourir le plus de kilomètres dans le
temps imparti
il faut trouver
les bons temps sur la piste pas s'est
déroulé entre eux
30 minutes 45 minutes passent et un
relais lorsque le concurrent est fatigué
en pis alors il ya toute une travée une
stratégie à adopter
et puis marquer aussi ses adversaires à
la fin des six heures c'est l'équipe de
paris cycliste olympique qui remporte la
compétition avec 1060 tours parcourus
sur la première heure les pistons ont
réussi à atteindre une moyenne de 50
km/heure c'était un objectif on était
venu là pour gagner
on a une super belle équipe avec trois
coéquipiers qui reviennent d'espagne
donc j'étais en forme et on a assuré on
a essayé de faire le show aussi on s'est
fait mal mais tout est bien qui finit
bien ont remporté une belle coupe une
belle victoire chez les féminines
l'équipe opère saint-michel remporte la
compétition avec 255 kilomètres
parcourus pendant ces six heures
nouvelle édition pourrait être organisée
l'année prochaine direction villepreux à
présent invités de marque étaient ce
samedi dans la commune lance un kick
boxeur professionnel français
aujourd'hui acteur jérôme le banner est
venu donner pour la première fois un
stage de pied poing une quarantaine
d'élèves du taï jitsu de villepreux
il est resté au total trois heures sur
place pour leur apprendre des techniques
de combat
ce sportif d'un mètre quatre-vingt-dix
pour cent vingt kilos de muscles
surnommé the bulldog of normandie était
au micro de notre journaliste d'un mètre
soixante marylène et iapichino comme
sont habitués à une certaine technique
qui se rapproche plus à lui du pape et
de l'aqueduc arrêté de la self défense
moi je sais plus ce côté on va dire eux
s'attendent à voir une mitraillette et
moi je veux avoir le bazooka
bon c'est bien d'avoir de désarmement il
faut apprendre ça germe dans le dans la
tête du professeur était réputée en fait
c'est juste un peu le sport dans toutes
les disciplines
il faut répéter répéter répéter héros
visé répéter on continue à parler de
venue de jérôme le banner à villepreux
avec le club de taï jitsu de la ville
qui a organisé cet événement nous
recevons sur ce plateau le président
georges moreira la secrétaire sophie
landais et l'instructeur robert gratis
tanak bonsoir bonsoir que c'était un
immense plaisir de recevoir
c'était se lire comme ça les i c'était
un énorme plaisir et un honneur de
recevoir jérôme le banner ça a été un
peu compliqué un peu rapide organisé
puisque madame le banner m'a contacté un
peu court mais c'était un challenge pour
nous et on a réussi un siège
ouais d'organiser en peu de temps un
stage avec une une légende du kickboxing
pour les amateurs vraiment les
connaisseurs c'était un challenge
d'organiser en peu de temps et de
pouvoir réunir parce que beaucoup de
gens aient aurait aimé venir et il y en
a d'autres qui aimeraient venir sans
venir enfin voila c'était plus très un
peu compliqué mais mais voilà il ya on
étaient une quarantaine à répond présent
et j'étais très content
que beaucoup de monde a répondu présent
à la venue de jérôme alors vous vous
étiez dans l'organisation mais vous
n'avez pas participé au stage
par contre havas gauche deux personnes
ont participé au stage sophie qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé
c'était juste exceptionnel franchement
si c'était à refaire il n'y avait pas de
souci je serai encore là il vous a
appris des techniques il ya des choses
qui sont qui vont rester dans ma tête ça
c'est sûr et certain
parce que c'est pas des choses qu'on
apprend tous les jours ne serait-ce que
angie camille cours de taï jitsu de la
semaine et je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
de vraiment exceptionnel et je pense que
que maintenant je vais monter sur le
tatami je pense que les récents
problèmes sans difficulté robert en tant
qu'instructeur qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé
le banner est ce que c'était un bon
instructeur également c'était un très
très bon instructeur et avec tout le raf
a de l'expérience derrière
effectivement je pratique depuis un
petit moment et j'avoue que qu'avoir des
stages comme ça qui ont pu être
organisées
or notre discipline ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut aussi souligner c'est à dire
que c'est pas du tout notre discipline
il a su se mettre à niveau il a su
participer
c'est à dire faire l'échauffement nous
montrer de très belles techniques
facilement applicable est effectivement
comme il a dit voilà il peut avoir une
mitraillette ou un bazooka peu importe
l'important c'est d'avoir des armes en
tout cas de faire du sport il reviendra
on sait on s'est regardés pourquoi pas
je pense que c'est à méditer pour que
les années à venir
on a parlé d'une année
est une fois tous les deux ans peut pas
régler pas tous les ans parce que je
pense que les gens peuvent s'ennuyer par
expérience mais je pense qu'une fois
tous les deux ans ça sera intéressant
dit méditer on va parler maintenant de
votre club
pourquoi avoir fondé ce club à ville
proche alors je ne suis que je ne suis
que le président depuis maintenant ma
huitième ou neuvième année
pratiquant déjà pas mal depuis
pratiquants maintenant depuis 19 et
enfin qu'en fait ça a été créé par par
des personnes avant moi
et je pense c'était la volonté de créer
un club de notre discipline qui est peu
connu certes mais qui est qui et qui est
qui et qui a le mérite d'être là
d'exister depuis les années 70 grâce à
maître daniel dubois co fondateur du taï
jitsu d'eau en france et nous voilà le
club a 31 ans et ça exactement nous
avons fêté en janvier
de mémoire on a en 2017 on a fêté nos
trente ans d'existence une crois que
c'est la deuxième association la plus
vieille de villepreux
alors est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter ce sport qui est cet art
martial qui n'est pas forcément connus
du grand public
bien sûr le teich dessus en fait c'est
un art martial français mais d'origine
japonaise qui mélange à la fois le
karaté le judo et l'aïkido donc maître
dubois a su condensé un petit peu les
meilleures techniques et en faire un art
martial abordable pour les européens que
nous sommes parce qu'effectivement on
n'a pas du tout la même philosophie
philosophie pardon que le conte les
japonais et en fait ça reste de la self
défense à voir tout ça reste bien sûr un
sport mais de la self défense et surtout
un art martial c'est à dire que au delà
d'appart rina patrick pardon sportive ça
permet aussi de nous éduquer d'avoir des
des règles du respect par rapport à son
partenaire par rapport à la vie et ça
nous aide moi j'ai grandi avec de la gym
qui peut servir dans la vie de tous les
jours la vie professionnelle dans la vie
toujours moi j'ai grandi je fais partie
des premiers vip rhodia donc c'est le
taï jitsu qui a fait un peu mon
éducation et je vous avoue qu
effectivement de pouvoir transpiré avec
des collègues sur tatami de pouvoir se
lâcher un petit peu et ben je vous avoue
qu'on sent beaucoup plus coup beaucoup
plus être content on sort et dans la vie
de tous les jours alors sophie vous
pratiquer cette discipline également
est ce que tout le monde peut pratiquer
franchement oui ben oui oui honnêtement
tout le monde peut le pratiquer
n'importe quelle taille n'importe quel
âge et honnêtement moi j'ai ma fille qui
est fait aussi également du taï jitsu
donc moi ça fait quatre ans que j'en
fais j'ai commencé
par le taille compacte et tout de suite
bas ma vie qu'elles étaient des gens
d'haïti dessus j'ai beaucoup apprécié
les techniques les enchaînements de kata
et et du coup j'ai du bas pourquoi pas
donc du coup j'ai commencé et j'ai
beaucoup apprécié en plus entre une très
bonne association dans lequel je me sens
vraiment très très bien je suis à l'aise
comme si que c'était ma deuxième famille
que je recommande un s'il ya quelqu'un
qui veut venir s'inscrire chez nous il
n'y a pas de souci et c'est vrai que non
je conseille à tout le monde de
d'essayer peu importe si on se
sous-estiment ou pas on y arrive quoi
qu'il arrive ils seront tous là pour
nous aider parce que niveau physique il
faut quand même un certain niveau
alors je vais pas vous mentir si vous
avez déjà un bagage sportif que soit
martial ou pas forcément vous est
avantagé mais l' avantage des cours et
l' avantage notamment de notre
professeur nicolas qui n'est pas la cas
peut pas venir ce soir c'est ya pas de
deux comme on pourra dire c'est pas
militaire donc chacun adapte les fort
par rapport à ses capacités et plus vous
voulez plus votre corps s'habitue et
plus vous êtes à l'aise et je vous avoue
que le retour des fêtes comme tout le
monde a été difficile même pour les plus
aguerris dont il ya pas deux voilà c'est
ça reste du sport et la pratique et
faire le professeur a là aussi pour tout
doucement ou faire monter en puissance
et avant tout se connaître avant de
pouvoir pratiquer pleinement ce sport
voilà donc on a parlé du tight contact
qui effectivement une partie de notre du
taï jitsu alors comment fait pour
s'inscrire justement simplement on peut
regarder sur internet agit-il contactez
le directement
et il ya les coordonnées en direct pour
les renseignements on est h24 puisque
c'est mon téléphone personnel donc il
est à 4 24 disponibles taï jitsu
villepreux et voilà on trouve toutes les
données sur internet et sur notre site
bien sûr puisque nous avons un site tête
et jitsu ville preuves mais combien
d'adhérents aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
on est dans une caja 45-45 parle à peu
près il reste de la place
bien sûr toute l'année on prend des
inscriptions merci à vous d'être passé
sur ce plateau n'hésitez pas à nous
solliciter si vous organiser d'autres
événements au sein du club on ne
manquera pas d'en parler sur tv 78 merci
beaucoup
si on ouvre une page sport automobile le
départ du 4l trophy 2010 9 est
programmée le 21 février depuis biarritz
parmi les 2600 étudiants attendus pour
ce raid entre la france et le maroc on
retrouva sur la ligne de départ de
plaisir oiseau volant de leur 4l justin
series et et marianne briel portrait de
ces deux têtes brûlées à un montage de
exigea séance studieuse pour marianne et
justine les deux étudiantes de 21 ans
originaire de plaisir ne sont pas en
train de réviser leurs cours mais de
préparer le 4l trophy un raid étudiant
solidaire entre la france et le maroc au
départ de biarritz au programme des 6000
km pistes désertiques d'une
réorientation à la boussole c'est une
expérience je pense que on voit en
apprendre beaucoup de cette aventure
notamment aux gones yeux au niveau
humain c'est par exemple il ya des gens
qui sont en galère ' on se voit on peut
s'arrêter et demander qu'est ce qui se
passe pour aider quoi c'est une belle
façon de découvrir le maroc et je
pensais attendait une aventure
inoubliable
j'espère qu'on n'aura pas trop guerrière
sur la route pour le pas avoir trop de
problèmes sur les chemins en sable et
les deux plaisirs oise ont testé leurs
voitures sur les routes du département
depuis son acquisition l'été dernier
les sportives ont également reçu des
cours de mécanique de la part d'un
garagiste local tous les genres on va
devoir checker le filtre r parce que
avec le sable il sera en sable et du
coup il va falloir ouvrir cette petite
boîte là et
et du coup à l'intérieur il ya le filtre
r on a une machine du coup qui va
souffler pour retirer tout stable
moi je me sentais tout cas l'air iqa dic
mais bon on connaît les petites bases et
franchement on a un mécano super au top
qui est superbe a cédé du coup par les
vieilles voitures donc je suis sûr que
la voiture allait elle est en état pour
partir aujourd'hui ces deux têtes
brûlées sont prêtes à faire chauffer la
gomme leur objectif sur cette course
terminée dans les 300 premiers du
classement
pour cela marianne et justes ils ont une
stratégie alterné leur rôle dans les
dunes c'est moi du coup le pilote et
marianne mako pilote qui va me guider
tout au long du 4ème jour en vrai on va
autant conduire l'une et l'autre mais
comme c'était moi qui avais proposé 4 l
trophy je me suis mis en tant que pilote
prochain arrêt pour les deux plaisirs
oise le 20 février prochain ils devront
se rendre au village départ à biarritz
avec leur 4l rose pour une dernière
vérification technique avant le grand
départ
le retour est lui prévu le 3 mars avec
des souvenirs à plein la tête
on souhaite bon courage à ces deux
aventurières on passe maintenant notre
page agenda
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda par de la boxe le
grand jour approche pour marvin petit le
boxeur de la team farrugia et l'encours
est en pleine préparation pour aller
chercher un titre de champion d'europe
des poids légers contre le belge
francesco patera le sportif enchaîne en
ce moment les mises de gants et les
sessions de haut niveau pour être fin
prêt pour son combat programmé le 16
février prochain en belgique il était au
micro de tv 78 je vais confiant parce
que je ne vais jamais pardon j'aime pas
je suis pas un pardon moi j'y vais j'y
vais pour le détruire c'est pas pour sa
part il fallut bien comme on dit comme
on dit chez nous je suis gitans on est
chez nous partout c'est pas parce que
c'est chez lui que ça y va il va faire
le patron n'y a pas de nier pas de ça
solo ring qui est un bonhomme le monde
qui au tour tu calcules pas et boxe on
continue cette page agenda part du
karaté un stage avec le maître now qui a
omis 8e dan est organisée ce samedi 9
février de 10 heures à 15 heures dans la
grande salle du palais des sports de
plaisir l'occasion de lui poser des
questions sur cette discipline si vous
voulez participer
le tarif est à 15 euros pour les adultes
et 10 euros pour les enfants et les
étudiants
il y aura également il y aura également
du football américain ce week-end les
templiers d'elancourt leaders invaincus
de leur poule en deuxième division
reçoivent les myrmidon de
savigny-le-temple les élans courtois
partiront favoris de la rencontre après
leur victoire 36 à 0 face aux diables
rouges de villepinte
si vous voulez les soutenir le match est
programmé ce samedi à 19 heures au
complexe sportif europe à elancourt
enfin on termine pas un rendez-vous
golfique le monde du golf va se réunir
du 12 au 24 au 14 avril à mantes la
jolie
la ville va accueillir pour la première
fois de son histoire le mondial du golf
le salon organisé au parc des exposition
proposera aux visiteurs de tester la
discipline et de découvrir le matériel
matériel des athlètes plus de vingt
mille personnes sont attendues pour ce
rendez vous c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour une un
nouveau magazine d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]